the world has changed in the last 10
years social media everything has
happened politically what have you how
how has parenting changed from your
first kid
to your fourth kid
i don't think it's changed much for us
that's not a big enough of a difference
in nine years okay i think the
difference is our era to the 20 year
olds today like a david yep versus my
kids i think it's i think it's 20 years
is how you engage it i don't think 10
years is enough to gauge the difference
so then answer their initial question
parenting changed
is it easier to be a dad today what was
his question it sounds easier to be
that's the versus 50 years ago is it i'm
going to tell you what there's there's a
um
you're going to let them answer it it's
tough to answer that question because i
don't think you'd be a single father 50
years ago
i think it's a different world today but
if you were if you were 50 years ago
versus today's probably going to be
harder 50 years ago than today the part
that's going to be tougher today is the
way the dad decides to be an involved
dad versus not an involved like there's
many ways you can make parenting easy
today you got a shitload of distractions
they're so easy to be a parent today but
to be a father who's leading his kids
that's a lot harder today than 50 years
ago
it's a lot harder today than 50 years
ago if you want to be a true father
that's leading your kids that's right
because 50 years ago how did you get
your porn how did you get your porn when
you were 14 years old i've never seen it
i'm still waiting 40 years some of your
friends that got porn magazines okay
yeah it was magazines what when you were
14 years old
okay and by the way even if it was
magazine give me the most hardcore thing
you ever saw in a magazine
here we go hardcore what are you going
to see
there's no way in the world you saw it
all
right 14 years old and house hustler
penthouse hustler wasn't that hard
whatever they had what do you know
what's today's hardcore do you know
what's going on i didn't live in
chatsworth in 2000. i don't
what i'm trying to say is there's way
more content today to psychologically
mess with a kid's mind today facts and
facts
so if you want to just be a father
have sex have a kid you just let them be
distracted by an ipad for 18 years you
can easily do it today with video games
but you ain't raising a leader it's just
a kid
it's a very very different uh mindset
you have 100 on the effort you got to
put in 50 years ago people lived with
their family unit more too so even if
you were a single dad chances were that
your family unit was very very close by
you had sisters cousins aunts uncles
mother father very very close within
that community as well
there wasn't the
idea of my sister lives in
chicago my father lives in in boston i
live you know what i'm saying like the
family unit was
geographically closer so you'd have more
of an insulated you know uh
um you know support system one of the
things that you have to deal with today
that's very very difficult though and we
just saw this with the you know election
the the education secretary cardona uh
the state is trying to take over control
of your kids that's not something you
had to deal with 50 years ago you didn't
have they they literally asked he was at
a uh
judicial senate judicial hearing
committee and i said who who is i forget
who the senator was asked the biden
secretary of education who is the
primary stakeholder
in a child's education the guy wanted to
answer one and a half million people
have taken their kids out of public
schools in the last year and a half
because of differences in political
ideologies and what they feel like is
extremism being taught in public schools
and then the guy won't answer and the
the senator doubles down and goes
does the parent have the primary right
to make decisions over a child's
education and the guy finally circles
back and says no the state the state has
just as much of a right this is a
community issue he won't say that the
parent is the primary stakeholder in a
child's education
children your kids that guy's kids are a
cultural battleground
yep that's the they're this is the the
kids are battleground so therefore back
in the day do you think
like when we're talking about parents
you think they put up with that now
yeah those parents no no way no way i
can't see my i can't see you can't see
your granddad or you can't see your
father or any teacher or any
administrator ever in a million years
telling my grandfather you know we have
more of a say over your child's
education than you do my grandfather
would have done things to that
administrator that would be you know
years in jail today years in jail for
sure there's no way there's no way that
they would have even had the the gall
and wherewithal you know and this guy
was a you know he was a a local 40 iron
worker you know he he liked education i
didn't even really care he's like
joining union with us we don't really
care you know like you know the school
is school was daycare for them you know
he knew all my uncles were going to join
the union with him so school was daycare
he didn't really care but if they tried
to tell him how to raise his kids
essentially they would get his literal
irish up and that would have been the
end of that for sure so for the
education secretary to sit there for the
whole world to say and see and say not a
state has more of a say than than the
parents do i mean how do you take that
like you said you're you're kidding me
do you realize what that does to me when
you say something like that i mean it's
just
pathetic to make it come i mean that's
exactly what they want to do they would
like to be able to do that and you as a
parent have to not fall for that yep you
as a parent has to be involved you as a
parent has to be have to be so involved
with the kid where you don't lose your
kid too many parents are losing their
kids because they're not involved enough
what do you mean what do you mean by
losing their kids he just said like with
the ipad with the being distracted doing
all those things you're being
participating but they're losing your
culture so let me let me explain to you
let me explain to how this thing works
so i read a book years ago called thank
god it's monday right and thank god it's
monday is this guy who's a psychologist
so talking about how most men in america
cannot wait for it to be monday to get
the hell away from the wife and the kids
because they want to be away they want
to be free they're saying thank god it's
monday rather than thank god it's friday
because friday the whole weekend and the
kids and the babysitting stuff starts
right so he's saying he watched all this
stuff with marriages what was
problematic and he said what i found out
relationships and marriages and parents
that worked
they gave individual time to their kids
regularly so if you're married you come
home you talk to your wife 10 minutes
how was your day babe you go to 10
minutes one on one right then you go to
your kids so tell me how was your day
101 then you find out one of them needs
a little bit more time then you go and
talk to them for 10 or 15 minutes or
one-on-one that one-on-one time takes
effort and most parents don't want to do
that that one-on-one time takes effort
it's just like in sales that one-on-one
time with your client that one-on-one
time on follow-up that one-on-one time
of writing the card to them most people
don't want to put that effort no
parents are losing their kids because
they're not having that one-on-one
conversation with their kids that's
right that's why i said when the guy
asks a question he's right it takes a
lot more work and effort today than it
did before because you have more things
to question yeah be more vigilant you
have to be today you have to be more
losing you have to be more passionately
passionately present with your own
offspring these are your offspring well
he's the one that holds your legacy
and uh like what pat's saying i mean
you know we've all seen pat with his
family and stuff and he does a great job
you know he's very involved you know but
how many parents are actually doing
those things and then like he said it it
requires effort you're supposed to grow
them
but you're not feeding them no it's not
it's not easy man it's listen that's why
i understand the argument today of not
having a kid i fully understand the
argument of not having a kid when people
make the argument of not having a kid i
get it you're better off not having a
kid
that you're not going to put time into
than having a kid
and you know
saying i don't have time to put the time
into it because you're just helping out
the institution more okay
it's so you don't do it then then you're
right i respect the person that says
like you know i sat down with a guy okay
one of the most powerful cfos in america
today he was in aig cfo when they went
to the government and raised 183 billion
dollars successful guy
within five years or six years they pay
back the 183 plus 21 billion dollars of
interest they were the first to pay back
aig as much as people trash aig they
paid it back gm still hasn't paid back
they paid her back i said so how long
you been married we've been married for
30 some years 20 some years
so how many kids you guys got we don't
have any kids why not my wife and i
chose 30 years ago that our careers are
kids
okay so now when a person hears that
what do they say what a freaking [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] why would you make your kid
you know it's a then another person will
say i would never do such a thing maybe
not a [ __ ] and another person may say
well what if they actually sat down and
talked about the fact that
they're not going to be able to put the
time into their kids that they'd like
and it's not fair for the kid okay great
that's actually better processing there
is a form of processing so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you